THURSDAY MARCH THIRD TWENTY
TWENTY TWO IS HEREBY CALLED
ORDER PLEASE READ ADVISER AUDIO
AND VIDEO RECORDING OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS BEING MADE AS ALSO
BE TELEVISED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ATTENDED THIS HEARING
MUST WEAR A MASK AT ALL TIMES
ATTENDEES MUST ALSO REFRAIN FROM
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS
OR OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THIS HEARING.
VIOLATIONS OF THESE RULES MAY
SUBJECT AN INDIVIDUAL TO REMOVAL
OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT PROCESS MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY HERE CUNNINGHAM THAT.
FLORA FONG. GIPSON HERE LEE
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS HERE RUBIO
THE ACROSS HERE. I'M YOU HAVE A
QUORUM WE HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA
IS OUR MOST ON THE CONSENT
AGENDA SECOND MOVE VEGETABLE
FOOD WAS SECONDED BY MR MATHIS
OF MR SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY HI COOLEY CUNNINGHAM
BENNETT. BENNETT HI FLORA FONG
FONG AYE GIPSON GIPSON AYE LI LI
I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS MATHIS AYE RUBIO RUBIO I
VEHICLES LAW- YOU PUT A HIGH
MOTION PASSES OF THAT MOTIONS
PASS AND THIS RULES COMMITTEES.
ARE GERMAN THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH.